During this brutal
moment in "The Fanatic,"
John Travolta's fingers get shot off.
This is what it looked
like in a test shoot
as the FX team was figuring out
how to make it work on camera.
To create fake injuries
for movies and TV shows,
makeup artists need an
intimate understanding
of the human anatomy in order to, say,
create an exact replica
of Travolta's hand,
and they need to know
what looks best on camera,
like using pressurized air
to blow the fingers off that replica.
Here's how seven gory
makeup effects are created.
For this scene in "The Irishman,"
where Robert De Niro stomps on
and breaks a shopkeeper's hand,
SPFX had to go beyond looks
and make something that would
also move realistically,
bending and breaking
in just the right way.
It started with molding the arm
in skin-like silicone mixed with plaster,
so the final piece was
somewhat translucent and rigid.
But instead of filling it in,
the FX artists added a metal armature,
a frame similar to what you'd see
inside a stop-motion puppet.
While the outer layer of
the arm provided rigidness,
this armature created more
bends in the hand and fingers.
When filming, they placed the fake arm
in actor Marco Greco's sleeve
and carefully positioned the camera
so that his body blocked his real arm.
The result was almost too effective.
According to SPFX's Brett Schmidt,
during one of the takes,
one of the fingers broke and spun around.
Exactly the kind of disturbing movie magic
they were hoping for.
In the 2019 film "The Fanatic,"
John Travolta's character
gets shot in the hand
and loses his fingers.
It's a gruesome moment
that primarily relied
on practical effects.
Special makeup effects artist
Mike Marino and his team
had to construct a
realistic-looking prosthetic hand
with detachable fingers.
They create the base like
any other prosthetic piece.
First, they cast it in silicone
for skin-like translucency,
with hairs punched in for realism.
They created the hand
and forearm together,
but they needed to attach
the fingers separately.
They rigged the fake
hand to a series of tubes
and pressurized air,
allowing the fingers to blow off on cue
and blood to spurt out of
the wounds at the same time.
To hide the apparatus from viewers,
they used a clever camera
angle that you can see here.
Watching the finished scene,
you'd never know the hand
wasn't attached to anything.
In the HBO series "I
Know This Much Is True,"
Mark Ruffalo's character
cuts off his own hand.
His resulting injury is
frequently visible on camera,
but creating the illusion
of a missing limb
requires not only digital effects,
but also careful attention
to practical details.
According to ProRen's Mike Marino,
a green glove would make his hand
look too long and unnatural.
So instead, Marino painted Ruffalo's hand
a specific shade of green.
This allowed FuseFX to digitally erase
his real hand from the shots.
With his hand gone,
Ruffalo also wore a prosthetic piece
to further emphasize the injury.
Marino made two designs
depending on which one the scene dictated:
a fresh, bloodier wound
and a cleaner, sewn-up wound.
In season two of "Westworld,"
actress Rinko Kikuchi
splits the Shogun's head in half.
But since the Shogun's body
continues to squirm around,
the team couldn't just
make a prosthetic head.
They had to consider the entire body.
Justin Raleigh and his
team at Fractured FX
also had to create this injury
with several different
camera angles in mind.
They first took a silicone
life cast of the actor's head
to capture every physical bit of his face.
They then made a replica out of clay,
which allowed them to sculpt details
before casting it in more silicone
and then punching in all the character's
head and facial hair.
Unlike other decapitated
heads on the show,
this one was split through the cheek,
meaning Raleigh had to
construct a tongue, esophagus,
and the surrounding muscle
and tissue inside the head.
But the trickiest part was this moment,
when the Shogun takes a few
steps before collapsing.
So the fake head was actually created
so it could be worn by a stunt performer,
and that blue hood he's wearing
allowed the VFX team to erase him,
so his real head wouldn't
pop up on camera.
Burn wounds are a common
injury in TV shows and movies,
but making them look realistic
involves a close attention
to texture and color.
So special makeup effects
artist Ben Bornstein
turns to a surprising reference:
burned chicken.
This is particularly
helpful in picking out
the color palette for fresh burns.
Heavy black in the deepest
part of the wounds,
shades of red, and lots of yellow.
Besides heavy prosthetics,
Bornstein can also create
convincing burns with much
less time-consuming methods,
like 3D-printed wounds
for background characters
or bald-cap vinyl pieces
that have actually been set on fire.
Some of these pieces are filled
with KY Jelly to create depth
and are then blended onto a painted spot
on a performer's arm.
In the end, the most
convincing form of this injury
is when all of these
methods are blended together
and you can't tell which is which.
In 1990's "The Grifters," John Cusack
gets slashed in the throat with glass.
This wound required a fake neck piece,
but back then, prosthetic pieces
were mostly made with foam latex,
which would have soaked up
all the fake blood used in the scene.
To make this piece last
through multiple takes,
StudioADI's Tom Woodruff
Jr. and Alec Gillis
constructed a fake neck out
of much sturdier gelatin.
Woodruff and Gillis then made an incision
in the appliance right here.
That would be the jugular vein,
which, according to Woodruff,
would make the character
realistically bleed the most.
They loaded blood into a large syringe
that was connected to a flexible
tube under Cusack's outfit,
which connected to a
flat tube under the neck.
When he got hit with the
briefcase and the glass shattered,
they pushed down on the syringe
and released the fake blood.
So it looks like the glass he's holding
is what really cuts him.
The operation scenes
Justin Raleigh worked on
in "Westworld" and "The Knick"
went far beyond squirts of blood.
Crafting realistic surgery wounds
involves thinking backwards,
down through the different
layers of skin, fat, and muscle.
When creating an original negative mold,
Raleigh works in reverse
to control the thickness of each layer.
From reading anatomy textbooks,
Raleigh realized that Thandiwe Newton's
inner skin layer wouldn't be bare,
but instead covered in a layer of fat.
Blending the pieces perfectly
into Newton's real skin
made it look like the wound
was actually part of her body.
But he did have to dial some details back.
By holding back on fake blood,
all of those muscles and vessels
specific to a human neck
looked much clearer on camera.
All of the deep research,
endless experimentation,
and knowledge of what looks good on camera
is what takes gore makeup
from good to great.
So the next time you see blood squirting
out of an actor's body,
remember that there was a whole crew
making sure they hit the right vein.